In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 15, on which we commemorate, the holy and
great martyr Nikitas, the Goth.
On the 15th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the holy martyr Nikitas, the Goth.
The glorious martyr Nikitas was born in the reign of Constantine the Great.
In the region near the mouth of the Danube, a Goth by birth, he was brought up in the faith
and love of God and with the desire to convert his countrymen through the care of his
devout parents and the teaching of Theophilos, the local bishop, who shone in the defense
of Orthodoxy at the Council of Nysia.
Nikitas was instructed in the holy scriptures by Theophilos successor, Ulphilas, who devised
an alphabet in order to translate the scriptures into the Gothic tongue and who laid upon Nikitas
the task of continuing his work and of spreading the faith among the people.
The Goth were divided into two hostile groups, one headed by Fritagern and the other by Athenaric,
a cruel and wicked man.
Unable to defeat Athenaric by himself, Fritagern secured the alliance of the Roman Emperor Valens,
who sent a legion with the cross on its standards that repulsed the forces of Athenaric, but
after a while, Athenaric regained power and let loose a violent persecution of Christians,
whom he had come to hate.
Nikitas was among the first to be captured since he was known to everyone as a tireless preacher
of the gospel.
He was tortured for his refusal to deny Christ, but this only resulted in hearing him proclaim
more strongly his faith and his love for the Savior.
In the end he was burnt to death and so gave his soul back to God and won the crown of victory
in the year 370.
A few years later the relics of Saint Nikitas were discovered through the miraculous appearance
of a star and taken to Mopswastia by his friend and disciple Marianos in the year 375.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.